il a ma chérie on a beau cadeau pour toi
isabelle est ce que tu as quelqu'un qui
a envie de voir en ce moment mon fait sa
copine ma meilleure amie
grâce à vous jamais revu le pilote grâce
à vous jamais revu d'accord lui est
alors déjà il est bête
est ce que tu as envie de revoir
quelques uns isabelle derrière survie
dos il ya la personne et on recommence
pas ouvrir le rideau s'il vous plaît
regardez la personne la personne est
déguisé en père noël pour l'instant ça
marche c'est père noël singer marie josé
pérec alors séparé que vous pouvez lui
poser des questions
il vous répondra que par oui ou non
aller si j'avais une minute pour trouver
de qui il s'agit est ce que vous êtes un
homme
oui est ce que vous êtes français nous
non mais il n'empêche les diabétiques
alliés d'hier bassil dit oui on peut ne
pas être français d oui oui ce que
faisait mon ses dires d'alger pas connu
est ce que vous venez de loin c'est pas
corneille je te dis oui oui est ce que
vous venez d états unis oui pourquoi
isabelle attentat peut être utilisé dès
qu'il s'agit est debout est ce qu on a
fait des choses ensemble qui sont à voir
ce serait las vegas oui est ce que vous
pensez à la personne à qui je pense je
pense à la personne à qui vous pensez
qu'il m'avait alors alors vous pensez
peut-être à on va voir le magnéto
peut-être à cette personne c'est
peut-être pas me regarder vous pensé lui
ou pour ses amis
non pas lui mais non
[Musique]
holmes
[Applaudissements]
que 120 quartiers
[Musique]
c'est perdu
[Applaudissements]
comment ça m'a donné donné merci d'être
venus les biens de et bien donné bien
des états unis pour isa you like izard
écouteurs et vaisseaux et merci et du
like you like very much
isabelle jeu l'adorent il savait ce que
ça te fait plaisir
non je déménagé à los angeles - le sénat
ma wii plus de cinéma elle est
magnifique et elle est en discussion en
direct et dans son salon les coûts des
savanes et faites vos petits bisous mais
à famille
[Applaudissements]
c'est une énorme surprise d'abeilles za
il avale ajouté suite de carhaix en
direct est assez mal elle te kiffe à ces
questions elle voulait vous faire une
petite danse tous les deux parties place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci voilà vous l'étiez un clip on y va
voilà j'espère connecter et jouer qu'on
applaudisse denain
[Applaudissements]